français l'aide durant son ministre
responsable de l'habitation au Québec
madame duranso bonsoir bonsoir Monsieur
bon je passe tout le monde va s'entendre
il y a pas de solution magique peut pas
poser sur un python puis qu'il y a une
offre de logement unique
mais là vous dans une pleine crise de
logement la première affaire vous dites
que vous que vous faites c'est d'enlever
un outil au locataire les sessions de
bail que vous voyez la réaction depuis
quelques jours puis en plus j'avais dit
à nos collègues de nouveau ils ont juste
à investir dans l'immobilier
le gros bout du bateau vous êtes
d'accord avec moi c'est les
propriétaires qui l'ont actuellement il
y a beaucoup de choses dans ce que vous
allez dire première chose je pense pas
que c'est la première chose que j'ai
faite le projet de loi le projet de loi
je l'ai dit c'est une un des outils pour
pour enlever des irritants pour créer un
contexte favorable pour construire
davantage pour inciter les
les gens à investir en immobilier des
gens construisent des condos ça nous
aide pas là au niveau des immeubles
multilocatifs alors il faut enlever des
irritants du côté propriétaire du côté
locataire aussi ce projet de loi-là
agit des deux côtés on a parlé
énormément des visions depuis mon entrée
en poste des rénovictions là on en parle
plus là aujourd'hui le projet de loi
justement adressait ses preuves en effet
plus difficile les évictions en
changeant le fardeau de la preuve quand
quelqu'un a pas signé l'accord on va
considérer qu'il est contre avant on
considérait qu'il était pour puis vous
augmentez les les compensations
ouais mais les sessions de bail je
reviens avec ça pourquoi vous mettez pas
ça de côté dans votre projet de loi en
disant j'ai vu la réaction c'est
peut-être pas le moment quand les
locataires sont à genoux de les coucher
à terre premièrement premièrement le
projet de loi et
je tenais à ce qu'il soit déposé avant
la fin de la session pour que justement
l'information soit dans la sphère
publique qu'on en discute et ça fera en
sorte qu'en septembre quand on va
retourner à Québec elle est
consultations va avoir lieu puis on va
écouter les gens il y a pas de problème
de ce côté-là mais là vous les avez
entendu donc vous pourriez mettre ça de
côté ceci dit j'ai dit faut créer un
climat un environnement qui est
favorable pour que les investisseurs les
propriétaires choisissent de faire du
logement multilocatif et cet élément là
des sessions bail session bail qui
demeure toujours possible locataire qui
veut quitter un logement a toujours les
mêmes droits la même possibilité de
quitter ce qu'on vient de dire c'est que
le propriétaire lui il a le droit de
choisir qui sera son prochain locataire
alors du point de vue du locataire
qui veut se départir de son obligation
c'est toujours là on donne des droits on
remet les droits aux propriétaires pour
mais d'avoir dit vous aviez juste
investi en immobilier ça je l'ai dit ce
matin à mon entrée ou à ma sœur à mon
entrée là au Comité ministériel ou à ma
sortie en fait que j'étais désolé que ça
semblait tout à fait insensible à la
situation au contraire je suis une fille
les gens qui me connaissent le disent
que je te fais une fille de cœur puis
que je fais les bonnes choses alors je
m'en suis excusé mais pour finir avec ça
la session est-ce que vraiment un
promoteur qui veut faire 16 logements ou
un 30 logements ou est-ce qu'il dit
vraiment je ne le ferai pas à Blainville
ou à Repentigny parce que il y a une
possibilité de session de bail c'est
beaucoup plus les taux d'intérêts les
matériaux tout ça c'est un ensemble de
choses les propriétaires de leur point
de vue le régime puis vous le voyez là
l'équilibre il est très mal il est très
difficile à maintenir entre locataire et
propriétaire alors déjà du point de vue
des propriétaires l'équilibre est
difficile même chose du côté des
locataires donc c'est un des éléments
qui fait sur lequel il fallait
travailler mais là j'aurais pour être
qui pourrait s'en aller dit on va
écouter à l'automne c'est une mesure qui
qui pertinente le problème actuellement
c'est la tempête parfaite l'accès à la
propriété plus difficile avec les taux
d'intérêt donc des gens qui restent
locataires donc ça fait moins de de
logement libre pour des gens qui
voudraient être locataires qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez faire pour encourager la
construction de multiplex en location
je travaille sur plusieurs choses en ce
moment on a parlé il y a quelques
semaines du groupe galop pour les
terrains de Blue bannette il y a une
équipe extraordinaire qui a été
assemblée qui est piloté là par janibe
du fond de solidarité et Monsieur Pierre
Boivin de chez Clarisse ces gens-là vont
se pencher oui spécifiquement sur le
terrain de bluebernet mais j'ai tous les
bons acteurs autour de la table pour
proposer des idées des solutions des
nouvelles façons de financer le logement
et dans les prochaines semaines on a dit
que c'était un comité d'accélération ça
alors dans les prochaines semaines et
moi on va avoir des résultats tout ça
moi je travaille déjà sur différents
d'autres outils financiers parce que la
demande ce matin là c'est 100 000 le
chiffre frappe mais 100000 unités de
logements à court terme au Québec c'est
possible vous y croyez être réaliste le
100000 il se construit pas ils se
construit pas comme ça ça va prendre un
certain temps lorsqu'on remarque c'est
historiquement les outils du
gouvernement du Québec c'était pour
financer du logement social du logement
abordable selon des critères bien
spécifiques selon un type de population
vulnérable et tout ça et ces outils là
ne répondent pas aux besoins actuels qui
sont plus larges donc je vais en trouver
d'autres une terminale une table de où
vous avez parlé de votre groupe avec la
rue j'ai donc une table plus large avec
des municipalités parce que les
municipalités ont du travail à faire
aussi dans réglementation tout ça est-ce
que on peut mettre ça créer ça pour
l'automne pour bientôt écouter moi je
parle avec toutes les municipalités on
parle déjà beaucoup de monde des comités
pour faire des comités on n'est pas on
n'est pas là dedans on est vraiment dans
l'action puis arrivé à l'automne au
contraire avec des annonces des
solutions concrètes merci beaucoup
d'être venu en direct sur notre plateau
je pense arriver tout juste de Québec
malgré la circulation je vais boucler la
merci Madame merci beaucoup